why did you make me do that look at me  focus on my voice I'm not giving up on  you Jean she was my friend  you're my family James no matter what  look your special gene and if you stop  fighting that force inside here  to embrace it  will possess the very power of a god  she'll kill us all tell me how we fix  this trough tell me what to do now don't  know what to do  what they don't understand  they fear and what they fear we seek to  destroy  it's your fault Charles I try to protect  her I'm scared  when I lose control bad things happen to  people I but the girl dies she's still  Jean we can still help her  sometimes you want to believe people as  something that they are not  by the time you realize who they are  it's too late  she's coming  [Music]  you